this story a North Carolina man I love
this as a massive new fortune thanks to
a cookie 66 year old Charles Jackson is
the winner of the more than three
hundred and forty four million dollar
Powerball jackpot that is the largest
lottery prize in North Carolina history
he opted for the 233 million dollar lump
sum payment mark man his formula for
success here it is Dana the retiree says
he's been playing numbers from this
fortune cookie I don't know what to do
with my stomach I hope you don't change
me a lot and I don't know try not to
change but I quit like I said I I'm
still gonna wear my jeans maybe new ones
but there are Jackson said he plans to
give a million dollars to his brother
and to make good on a deal that they had
if either brother ever won them I didn't
even know they had numbers in fortune
cookies I heard saying no saying that
and usually there's a number to it we
got to flip it over you got to flip it
over sometimes some of them have them on
it mine said the last one I got said the
fortune singers okay is it another
cookie
no it's maybe it wasn't okay those are
your numbers
no thank you we're happy for Charles
Jackson the delivery guy on that Chinese
food though we hope he doesn't change
too thank you it doesn't he's got